the world has been paying tribute to
queen elizabeth ii in her role as head
of the commonwealth of nations the queen
helped advance a new international order
of peace and prosperity
she ascended the throne only a few years
after the petition of india both
pakistan and bangladesh were created out
of india all three members of the
commonwealth but not without their
differences
prime minister narendra modi met queen
elizabeth twice during trips to the uk
he warmly remembered the queen showing
him a handkerchief given to her by
mahatma gandhi the pm tweeted she'll be
remembered as a stalwart of our times
she provided inspiring leadership to her
nation and people personified dignity
and decency in public life
our delhi bureau chief amrita chima
joins us so we saw modi's message of
condolence what's been the reaction in
india
ben tributes have been pouring in since
the news came in and the news came in in
india late last night so the most of the
newspapers didn't catch more than just a
short headline on the news of the
queen's passing but there's a lot of
stuff online and the televisions are
giving a lot of coverage a lot of the
comments are coming from politicians one
local politician described uh
queen elizabeth as a person who had
shown courage wisdom and praised her
service uh to the nation and then you
had another person talking about you
know she's a wonderful person she was a
true friend of india so a lot of
coverage on the queen's passing here in
delhi
the queen ascended the throne just after
indian independence she really was the
face of the evolving relationship
between india and the uk wasn't she
in many ways yes ben because she became
a queen five years after india got
independence in 1947 and she came to
india 11 years later now her first visit
was in 1961 and she talked about the
warmth and hospitality of indians and
she also talked about the richness and
diversity of india which she said was an
inspiration to people like her so her
next visit then was uh in
1983 and that's the time when the
commonwealth heads of government were
meeting here in delhi and that was also
the time that she famously gave mother
teresa an order of merit and at that
time indira gandhi india's female prime
minister was there and it was wonderful
to see these pictures we've been seeing
in recent hours of the two strong
competent and elegant ladies obviously
enjoying each other's company and the
final visit went to india was in 1997
and that was when india was marking 50
years of independence and that's when
the queen for the first time
acknowledged the colonial history
between the two countries and she talked
about difficult episodes of colonial
history and mentioned specifically a
famous massacre at julia wallabang so
obviously she had acknowledged something
that meant a lot to people here in india
and rita do you have any personal
memories of the queen
well actually i have to you know when i
was a very little girl i was obviously
quite kind of mesmerized by the whole
royalty thing so i wrote a letter to the
queen uh asking about her and asking her
for a photo obviously i didn't get a
reply back from her but i did get a
reply from her lady in waiting saying
she'd been instructed by her majesty to
thank me for my letter
and the second episode was actually uh
much later when i was a student
yeah and that's it and the second time
ben was when i was a student in england
at oxford university and she was our
chief guest at a rhodes scholars
function so i remember that she came by
and you know we were all dazzled by a
very neon colored outfit she just walked
past me but prince philip he stopped by
and exchanged a few words uh with me but
that wasn't good enough for me i wanted
to talk to the queen
and reader uh tell me what is the
commonwealth now without queen elizabeth
ii
i think most people will say quite
diminished because many people felt in
the comment well that she was the glue
that held this grouping together because
people had personal regard for her even
though some people feel that this whole
commonwealth thing is a bit outdated but
they felt that till she is there that
this organization was worth being a
member of now but things are changing
also in india as we saw just very
recently at the indian prime minister he
renamed this street just behind me it
was called king's way earlier linked
with the colonial past it's now been
named the path of duty and what he said
the prime minister was india has got rid
of a symbol of slavery so you see that
there's a great desire here in this
government to get rid of the colonial
legacy and i'm sure that will also have
an impact on india's links with the with
with the commonwealth and reeduca for us
in delhi thank you very much
reactions to the queen's passing have
been pouring in from around the region
singapore's leader lee shen long
described elizabeth ii as the very heart
and soul of the uk taiwanese president
tsai inguin said her country remembers
and celebrates her life of leadership
and service which set an example for
people around the
world and japan's prime minister fumio
kishida also paid tribute to the queen
for strengthening ties between his
country and the uk
this is a huge loss
not only for the british people
japan will be with the people of britain
in overcoming this deep sorrow
china has also offered condolences but
the queen's passing is more acutely felt
in hong kong the british ruled the
territory for over 150 years before
handing it back to the chinese in 1997.
people have been gathering outside the
british consulate the union jack flying
at half-mast
elizabeth visited hong kong twice during
her reign in 1975 and 86 when it was
still a british outpost here are some
reactions from hong kongers
i miss the queen very much and i'm very
grateful to her for the many years she
ruled over hong kong
when i learned of her passing away this
morning i felt a pang of sadness
it's possible that we've always had a
firm handle on the circumstances of the
british royal family as i grew up this
feels both distant and close
i remember her visiting hong kong in the
early days of her reign
grandiose and influential oh the general
public felt she was beautiful and
wonderful
and over to dw correspondent phoebe kong
tell us more about the reaction in hong
kong
oh well queen elizabeth and the royal
family is of course no stranger to hong
kong residents and
like just last night when the news broke
many people took to social media to
mourn the death of the queen and today
more and more people online offline on
paying tribute to this legendary [ __ ]
that many people went to the british
consulate general in hong kong to
leave flowers and also messages
to the book of all
condolences and
people saying that they pay a respect
and also gratitude to the queen that
have um like rude hong kong uh for a
decade before hong kong was handed back
to china and uh also there was some like
reaction from the government that
despite at the times of some kind of the
tensions between china and hong kong
government and also the uk
but then hong kong chief executive john
lee gave a short statement saying that
she
he expressed profound sadness and
condolences
to the death of the queen and he
described that the queen was greatly
respected and praised by the british
people so that's the reaction from the
hong kong government and when we look at
the media coverage that um like of
course this is one of like the biggest
news today in hong kong because people
feel so connected with um the uk and
also the queen herself but then um
because of the political climate here
and and also kind of like a sensitive uh
matters of covering about the uk
royal family that some of the
media appear to have some
self-censorship that i've heard from
some of the friends from um the newsroom
working in hong kong they said like some
editors like have the cell center some
of the news coverage to tune down on the
coverage and not to like play it too big
can you describe for me in more detail
that connection there
to the uk and the monarchy especially
for the older generation
uh yes hong kong had been like um like
under british food for over 150 years
and um and the most important era that
is the post-war era was under the reign
of the queen elizabeth and uh
interestingly like people in hong kong
call the queen as um the the boss lady
that is the nickname given um to the
queen by the general public that is like
a cantonese nickname so so so we can
feel the sense of like special
attachment and special connection
between the hong kong um people and then
and to the queen herself and then like
but that's not only limited to the older
generation is also um the younger
generation that feels that like um the
the greatest legacy left by the queen
and the colonial governments that
she led is that um like making hong kong
from a fish village to one of the most
successful international cities by like
laying like important infrastructure to
at the society um say the judiciary
educational the medical system and and
the very important like administrative
uh system that that have left hong kong
so successful in many aspects so um for
many people um the queen represents uh
the those good old times of hong kong
that especially when hong kong is facing
like political upheavals after the
hanover so many people like miss those
times like under the colonial rule and
like even until today we we still see
some like um science and footprints of
of the queen like many
important facilities like the hospitals
some public schools are named after
queen elizabeth and and even some coins
like with her face on it still circulate
until today so she's kind of like still
living memories for for many residents
in hong kong
phoebe kong on the boss lady and her
footprint in hong kong thank you
well apart from the uk queen elizabeth
was the monarch of 14 countries one of
those was papua new guinea which like
nearby australia and new zealand woke up
today with a new head of state king
charles iii here's png's prime minister
james marapi
from the mountains
the valleys
the planes the islands and the lowlands
of our country
in the 600 plus islands that we call
papua new guinea
the entire nation stand
in
silence
and offer our
deepest analysis
well that's it for this week more
coverage on the queen's legacy on our
website we leave you with her many trips
to asia during her long reign bye-bye
[Music]
[Music]
you